imagine ed miliband limping into office  aided by the crutch of the SNP is he or  is he not prepared to barter a work on  nuclear deterrent except that you  stabbed her own brother in the back now  you're willing to stab the country in  the back to comments like that ever  really get to you know ed miliband can  only get to Downing Street on the back  of SNP support I think David Cameron  should be ashamed he's got nothing  positive to say about the future of the  country no forward vision for the  country sends out is merely by Michael  Fallon look we will not walk for trident  and we will not walk for anything that  facilitates the renewal of China  elections people say this obliging  things about each other once you fix  here you got to keep it keep it in good  order as you can perhaps tell them i  would think I come to election fever